electric charge is a property that some
but not all fundamental particles in
nature have the most commonly talked
about fundamentally charged particles
are the electrons which orbit the
outside of the atom these are negatively
charged there's also the protons which
reside inside the nucleus and these are
positively charged and the neutrons
inside the nucleus don't have any net
charge it turns out that all
fundamentally charged particles in the
universe have charges that come in
integer units of the elementary charge
so if you find a particle in nature it's
going to have a charge of 1 times this
number 2 times this number 3 times this
number and it could be positive or
negative
for instance the electron has a charge
of negative one point six times 10 to
the negative 19 coulombs and the charge
of the proton is positive one point six
times 10 to the negative 19 coulombs
however most atoms in the universe are
electrically neutral overall since
they'll have just as many negative
electrons as they do positive protons
but if an atom had too many electrons
overall that atom would be negatively
charged and if an atom had too few
electrons that atom would be overall
positively charged and something that's
really important to remember is that the
electric charge is always conserved for
every process in other words the total
charge initially is going to equal the
total charge finally after any process
so it's an example problem involving
electric charge look like let's say
three identically sized metal spheres
start off with the charges seen below
positive 5 q positive 3 Q and negative 2
Q if we touch sphere X 2 sphere Y and
separate them and then touch sphere Y 2
spheres E and separate them what will be
the final charge on each sphere well
first when we touch X 2 y the total
charge has to be conserved there's a
total charge of 8 Q amongst them and
since they're identically sized they'll
both share the total charge which means
after they touch they'll both have
positive for Q if one of the spheres
were larger it would gain more of the
charge but the total charge would still
be conserved and now when sphere Y is
touched to sphere Z the total charge
amongst them at that moment would be
positive for Q plus negative 2 Q which
is positive 2 Q they would share it
equally so sphere Y would have
positive cue and spheres II would also
have positive q so the answer here is c
opposite charges attract and like
charges repel
and what Coulomb's law does is it gives
you a way to find the magnitude of the
electric force between two charges the
formula for Coulomb's law says that the
magnitude of the electric force between
two charges Q 1 and Q 2 is going to
equal the electric constant K which is
nine times 10 to the ninth times the
product of the two charges measured in
coulombs divided by the center-to-center
distance between those two charges
squared you can't forget to square this
distance and it's got to be in meters if
you want to find SI units of Newton's
for the force also don't rely on the
negative and positive signs of the
charges to tell you which way the force
points just use the fact that opposite
charges attract and like charges repel
and use Coulomb's law to get the
magnitude of the force so what's an
example problem involving Coulomb's law
look like let's say two charges exert an
electric force of magnitude F on each
other what would be the magnitude of the
new electric force if the distance
between the charges is tripled and the
magnitude of one of the charges is
doubled well we know the formula for
Coulomb's law says that the force
between two charges is the electric
constant times one of the charges times
the other charge divided by the distance
between them squared and now once we
triple the distance and double a charge
the new electric force is going to be
the electric constant times one of the
charges multiplied by two times one of
the charges divided by three times the
distance which is squared so I'm going
to get a factor of two on top and this
three will get squared which gives me a
factor of nine on the bottom if I pull
out those extra factors I get that the
new force is going to be two ninths
multiplied by K q1 q2 over d squared but
this entire quantity was just the old
force F so the new force is going to be
two ninths of the old force the
electrical current I tells you the
amount of coulombs of charge that passes
a point in a wire per second so if you
watch some point in a wire and you count
how many coulombs of charge passed by
that point per second that would be the
current or an equation form we can see
that the current I is going to be the
amount of charge that flows past a point
in a wire per
this gives the units of AI as coulombs
per second which we abbreviate as an
ampere and since charging time aren't
vectors current is not a vector either
something that's kind of strange is that
the so-called conventional direction of
current would be the direction that
positive charges flow within a wire
however positive charges don't flow
within a wire the only charges that
actually flow in a wire are negative
charges but it turns out that negative
charges flowing to the left is
physically the same as positive charges
flowing to the right so in most physics
problems we pretend as if it were the
positive charges moving
however it's really the electrons which
are negative that are moving within the
wire so what's an example problem
involving electrical current look like
let's say three amps flows within a
circuit how much charge would pass by a
point in that wire during a time
interval of five minutes well we know
the definition of current is the charge
per time that means the charge is going
to be the amount of current multiplied
by the time so we take our current of
three amps and we multiply by the time
but we can't multiply by five because
that's in units of minutes since amps is
coulombs per second we've got to convert
five minutes into seconds which would be
five minutes multiplied by 60 seconds
per minute which would give us a total
amount of charge of nine hundred
coulombs the resistance of a circuit
element measures how much that element
will restrict the flow of current the
larger the resistance the less current
that will be allowed to flow and the
definition of a resistance is given by
Ohm's law Ohm's law states the amount of
current that you'll get through a
portion of a circuit is going to be
proportional to the voltage across that
portion divided by the resistance of
that portion of the circuit so between
these two points the amount of current
that will flow is going to be equal to
the voltage between those two points
divided by the resistance between those
two points so the larger the resistance
the less current will flow but the
greater the voltage supplied the greater
the current will be and this is what
Ohm's law says even though Ohm's law
gives you a way to define the resistance
you can determine the resistance of a
circuit element by knowing the size and
shape of that circuit element in other
words the resistance of a cylindrical
resistor is going to be equal to the
resistivity which is a measure of an
object's natural resistant
to current multiplied by the length of
that resistor the longer the resistor
the greater the resistance and the more
it will resist the flow of current and
then divided by the cross-sectional area
of that resistor which would be this
area right here that current is either
flowing into or out of if the resistor
is cylindrical the area of this circle
would be pi times R squared where little
R would be the radius of this cross
sectional area the units of resistance
is ohms and it is not a vector it is
always positive or zero so what's an
example problem involving Ohm's law or
the resistance of a cylindrical resistor
look like let's say a battery of voltage
V is hooked up to a single cylindrical
resistor of length L and radius little R
and when that's done a current I is
flowing through the battery
what is the resistivity Rho of that
resistor well we know Ohm's law states
that the current that flows through a
portion of a circuit will be equal to
the voltage across that portion divided
by the resistance of that portion and
this means the resistance of this
resistor is going to be the voltage of
the battery divided by the current
2-factor resistivity into this we have
to use the formula for the resistance of
a cylindrical resistor which is Rho
times L over a this gives us the
resistance of the resistor which has got
to equal V over I and now we can solve
for the resistivity Rho we get V times a
over IL but since we're given the radius
little R we've got to write the area in
terms of that radius so there's going to
be V times PI R squared divided by I
times L which gives us an answer of C
when dealing with complicated circuits
with many resistors you often have to
reduce those resistors into smaller
equivalent amounts of resistors and the
two ways you do this are by finding two
resistors that are in series or in
parallel resistors will be in series if
the same current that flows through the
first resistor flows through the next
resistor if the current branched off in
between them these resistors would no
longer be in series but if they're in
series you can find the equivalent
resistance of this section of wire by
just adding up the two individual
resistances so the current for resistors
in series must be the same but the
voltage might be different since they
could have different resistances two
resistors will be in parallel if a
current comes in splits into two parts
goes through one
resistor each and then rejoined before
hitting anything else in the circuit and
if this is the case you can find the
equivalent resistance of this portion of
the circuit ie between these two points
by saying that 1 over the equivalent
resistance is going to equal 1 over the
resistance of the first resistor plus 1
over the resistance of the second
resistor but be careful 1 over r1 plus 1
over r2 just gives you 1 over R
equivalent if you want R equivalent
you're going to have to take 1 over this
entire side in order to get R equivalent
so what's an example problem involving
resistors in series and parallel look
like let's say we have the circuit shown
below and we want to know what current
flows through the 8 ohm resistor now you
might be tempted to say that since Ohm's
law says that the current is Delta V
over R we can just plug in the voltage
of the battery which is 24 volts divided
by the resistance of the resistor which
is 8 ohms and that would give us 3 amps
but that's not right at all when using
Ohm's law the current that flows through
a resistor R is going to be equal to the
voltage across that resistor divided by
the resistance of that resistor so if we
plug 8 ohms into the denominator we've
got to plug in the voltage across that 8
ohm resistor but the voltage across the
8 ohm resistor is not going to be the
full 24 volts of the battery it's going
to be less than 24 volts in other words
the battery provides a voltage between
this point and this point of 24 volts
but there's going to be voltage drops
across the six and 12 ohm resistors
which make it so that the voltage across
the 8 ohm resistor is not going to be
the full 24 volts so we have to reduce
these resistors to a single resistance
the 6 and the 12 are in parallel so we
can say that 1 over 6 plus 1 over 12
would equal 1 over the resistance of
that portion of the circuit this is
going to equal 3 twelfths which is 1/4
so that means that parallel portion of
the circuit has an equivalent resistance
of 4 ohms so between this point and this
point there are 4 ohms of resistance and
that equivalent resistance is in series
with this 8 ohm resistor so we can add 4
and 8 and get 12 ohms of total
resistance and now I can say that the
full 24 volts of the battery is applied
across this entire equivalent resistance
of 12 ohms so if I come up here and
change this 8 ohms to 12 ohms of
equivalent resistance for the total
circuit
I'll get the correct current that flows
through the battery of two amps and
since that's the current that's flowing
through the battery that had to be the
current that's flowing through the eight
ohm resistor as well since this 8 ohm
resistor and the battery are in series
elements in a circuit often use
electrical power that is to say when
current runs through a resistor the
electrons moving through that resistor
turns some of their electrical potential
energy into energies like heat light or
sound and the rate at which these
electrons are turning their energy into
other forms of energy is called the
electrical power so the rate at which a
resistor is turning electrical potential
energy into heat is the electrical power
used by that resistor in other words the
amount of energy converted into heat
divided by the time it took to convert
that energy is the definition of the
power and there's a way to determine
this number of joules per second in
terms of quantities like the current the
voltage and the resistance the power
used by a resistor can be written as the
current through that resistor multiplied
by the voltage across that resistor or
if you substituted Ohm's law into this
formula you'd see that this is
equivalent to the current through that
resistor squared multiplied by the
resistance of the resistor or it could
rearrange these formulas to get the
power used by a resistor would also be
the voltage across that resistor squared
divided by the resistance of that
resistor all three of these if used
correctly will give you the same number
for the power used by a resistor and if
you wanted to determine the number of
joules of heat energy converted you
could set any one of these equal to the
amount of energy per time and solve for
that energy the units of electrical
power are the same as the regular units
of power which is watts ie joules per
second an electrical power is not a
vector so it's an example problem
involving electrical power look like
let's say a light bulb of resistance R
is hooked up to a source of voltage V
and a second light bulb of resistance 2
R is hooked up to a source of voltage 2
V how does the power used by the second
light bulb compared to the power used by
the first light bulb since we have
information about R and V I'll use the
version of the power formula that says
that the power used by a resistor is
going to be Delta V squared over R so in
terms of quantities given the power used
by the first light bulb is going to be V
squared over R and the power used by the
second light bulb
is going to be equal to the voltage
across the second light bulb which is
two times the voltage across the first
light bulb and we square that divided by
the resistance of the second light bulb
which is going to be two times the
resistance of the first light bulb the
two squared on top is going to give me a
factor of four and I'll have another
factor of two on the bottom so if i
factor out this four divided by two
I get the power used by the second light
bulb is going to be two times V squared
over R but V squared over R was the
power used by the first light bulb so
the power used by the second light bulb
is going to be two times the power used
by the first light bulb and so the light
bulb of resistance to R has twice the
power and that means it'll be brighter
the quantity that determines the
brightness of a light bulb is the
electrical power of that light bulb it's
not necessarily the resistance or the
voltage it's the combination of the two
in this formula that will tell you the
electrical power and therefore the
brightness of the light bulb two of the
most useful ideas and circuits are
referred to as kirchoff's rules the
first rule is called the junction rule
and it states that all the current
entering a junction must equal all the
current exiting that Junction in other
words if you add all the current that
flows into a junction that has to equal
all the current that flows out of that
junction because current is just flowing
charge and charge is conserved so charge
can't be created or destroyed at any
point in this circuit no more than water
can get created or destroyed within a
series of pipes and the second rule is
called the loop rule which states that
if you add up all the changes in
electrical potential ie voltages around
any closed loop in a circuit it'll
always add up to zero so if you add up
all the voltages encountered through a
closed loop through a circuit it always
adds up to zero and this is just a
result of conservation of energy the
electrons will gain energy when they
flow through the battery and they'll
lose energy every time they flow through
a resistor but the total amount of
energy they gain from the battery has to
be equal to the total amount of energy
they lose due to the resistors in other
words if we consider a complicated
circuit that has a battery and three
resistors the total current flowing into
a junction I 1 would have to be equal to
the total current coming out of that
Junction I 2 and I 3 since no charge
gets created or destroyed and that means
when these two currents combine again
the total current flowing
out of that section is going to again be
I won and if we follow a closed loop
through this circuit the sum of all the
voltages around that loop have to add up
to zero ie the voltage of the battery
minus the voltage drop across the first
resistor minus the voltage drop across
the second resistor would have to equal
zero so what's an example problem
involving Kirchhoff's rules look like
let's say we have the circuit below and
we wanted to determine the voltage
across the six ohm resistor to do this
we could use the loop rule I'll start
behind the battery and I'll go through
the resistor I wanted to determine the
voltage across I'll add up all the
voltages across that loop and set it
equal to zero so the voltage across the
battery is going to be positive 24 volts
minus the voltage across the six ohm
resistor and then minus the voltage
across the 8 ohm resistor has to equal
zero but we're given this current so we
know that 2 amps flows through the 8 ohm
resistor and you can always determine
the voltage across a resistor using
Ohm's law so the voltage across the 8
ohm resistor is going to be 2 amps which
is flowing through the 8 ohm resistor
multiplied by 8 ohms and we get 16 volts
which I can plug in to here and this
gives me 24 volts minus the voltage
across the 6 ohm resistor minus 16 has
to equal zero and if I solve this for
the voltage across the six ohm resistor
I get 24 volts minus 16 volts which is 8
volts so the voltage across the 6 ohm
resistor would be 8 volts note because
the 12 ohm resistor and the 6 ohm
resistor in parallel the voltage across
the 12 ohm resistor would also be 8
volts because the voltage across any two
elements in parallel have to be the same
volt meters are the device that you use
to measure the voltage between two
points in a circuit when hooking up a
voltmeter you've got to hook it up in
parallel between the two points you want
to find the voltage across in other
words to determine the voltage between
this point and this point which would be
the voltage across R 3 you would hook up
the voltmeter in parallel with r3 a
meters are the devices we use to measure
the electrical current that passed
through a point in a circuit and a
meters have to be hooked up in series
with the circuit element you want to
determine the current through in other
words if we wanted to determine the
current through r1 we would hook up the
ammeter in series with r1
note that for these electrical devices
to work well the ammeter should have
almost zero internal resistance thereby
not affecting the current that flows
through the circuit and voltmeter should
have near infinite resistance so that it
doesn't draw any of the current from the
resistor in reality ammeters have a very
small but nonzero internal resistance
and voltmeters have a very high but not
infinite internal resistance so what
would an example problem involving
voltmeters and ammeters look like let's
say we have the circuit shown below and
these numbered circles represent
possible places we could stick a
voltmeter to measure the voltage across
the eight ohm resistor which two of
these volt meters would correctly give
the voltage across the eight ohm
resistor and you have to be careful some
AP problems are going to require you to
select two correct answers for the
multiple choice so be sure to read the
instructions carefully voltmeter number
four is a terrible choice you never hook
up your voltmeter in series with the
circuit element you're trying to find
the voltage across and voltmeter number
one is doing nothing really because it's
measuring the voltage between two points
in a wire with nothing in between that
wire so the voltage measured by
voltmeter one should just be zero since
the voltage across a wire of zero
resistance should just give you zero
volts so the correct choices would be
voltmeter number two which gives you the
voltage across the eight ohm resistor
and voltmeter number three which also
gives you an equivalent measurement of
the voltage across the resistor 8 ohms